Alright, playtime is over.
Time to get some lunch.
Yay!
Come on Peter, let's go get lunch with my mom and then we can race when we get back.
Wait Maria, your mom said to put the toys away.
Oh that's okay, we can put them away when we get back.
But Maria, you should always clean up your toys after playtime.
We're going to keep playing with the toys when we get back.
Isn't it just easier to leave them out?
When playtime is over, we should clean up.
It's not safe to leave toys out.
Why isn't it safe to leave toys on the floor?
Someone could trip over them and get hurt.
And the toys could get broken too.
Oh no! I don't want anyone to get hurt!
You're right, we should clean up the toys when playtime is over.
Will you help me?
Sure!